hello everybody what da [ __ ] hello
everybody my name is markiplier welcome
rubber band
watermelon explosion challenge where
we're gonna be putting rubber bands
around these tiny infinitesimal
watermelons because they're not in
season
infinitesimal thank you everyone yes
it's a word anywhere we're gonna be
doing this we're gonna be going up gets
teen edge we don't know how long this is
take got it cut we don't know how long
this is gonna take so we got a giant
pile of about a couple thousand rubber
bands here and we're just gonna keep
adding them onto these tiny melons and
hope for the best three two one go just
all in the same spot we should all have
one ready so it should be ready hold it
you're at him me you yeah ee well it
hurt Emily from my killer dude Amy even
away from us like a little block so they
don't shoot off our you're near Cydonia
so I'm I'm in handling hold it like a
man oh no no you can't don't be weird
wait wait hold it man don't we must win
it the most puppies that
never compute I don't want the thing to
blow up in my face
and check this yeah it's a lot of your
regular whining the god we fine don't
worry about it'll be fine
six youtubers loser and a horrible water
every single one of them a horrible
Walker fun you guys are going slow so it
doesn't explode on you
no not sure likely with little water
Matt you got take your turn quicker I'm
sorry I'm scared
potentially hurt you really I've seen
some of these explode pretty good really
well now you tell us I know that you saw
the watermelon explosion challenge for
nothing I'm just gonna crush it's just
gonna implode everyone's starting to
flinch away there's another family on
the shaver burner and Cheney yes it is
actually I feel it no I feel ideally to
me okay
it's gonna blow my fingers off nice
clothes nice it's not like an actress no
she fans turn it into steam or blowing
hands do they might be catching up man
ours maybe just not wanting to do it
match I'm scared all right your job is
to hold a watermill rubber band I really
see oh my god it's so cool yeah there we
go
oh my god we gotta get ours we gonna get
our victory tastes bad I wasn't it
doesn't sound like I'm ready Oh Oh Leroy
look at it look at it blossoms like
blossomed all right Bo I look at it
looks like the top is like blossomy I
really wait you guys are off camera
through enough
you're off come come over here this end
where yes why are you eating their melon
sorry should we help oh no no no no what
about this I want to finish this strong
pull the season tickets oh oh it's very
bottom up oh I don't know
take the rubber bands about it hold that
you pansies all right go go go go go
I'm gonna get one more it's gonna blow
Oh put three out of it looks like a
space just no heat liner did you use
watermelon baby there we go there yeah
rubberband oh my god I'll call this
piece one look at this thing
is this yours or mine oh I scooped out
of it okay that's a easy how your missus
go puddin
I ate it like an animal just like a
human mmm
alright so thank you everybody so much
for watching we do have other water dogs
so check out key measures channel to see
if we did another version of this
channel thanks again ever oh hey good
job check out team edge they're cool we
might have done another challenge actual
we've done a whole bunch of challenge so
check out all the ones that we've done
in the past and the next one sits over
there right now
thanks again everybody we'll see you
next one bye
you